ça me fait plaisir de vous en parler ce
que vous connaissez cette marque diva
corps d'yves accord dont n'a pas vous en
ai parlé on était à las vegas venez par
là on était à las vegas on l'était au
crs il faisait beau il faisait chaud
tout allait bien alors tout va bien
aujourd'hui fait un petit peu moins bon
il fait un petit peu moins chaud mais on
parle quand même de cette très jolie
marque d'yves accordent-ils accord
existe depuis dix ans et qui font du
bien aux oreilles grâce à leurs
écouteurs alors aujourd'hui on va se
parler d'un travail parler de nouveau un
tracé la deuxième génération des
antilles pause je sais pas si vous avez
connu les antipodes première génération
sont les écouteurs qui avait bien marché
qu'elle lui un vrai succès au niveau de
la presse et les rails avec une deuxième
génération alors cette deuxième
génération s'attendaient depuis un petit
moment parce qu'effectivement depuis le
mois de janvier
eh bien j'avais hâte de les tester c'est
aujourd'hui chose faite donc vous donner
aujourd'hui mon retour sur ces intra
100% français pour vous dire s'ils sont
intéressants oui non est-ce qu'ils sont
faits pour vous j'aime bien ça allait
est-ce qu'ils sont faits pour vous et
est-ce qu'il faut venir se positionner
juste parce que vous le savez en plus
c'est extrêmement important en ce moment
de venir soutenir les entreprises
françaises dit l'accord est une
entreprise française située à metz donc
si vous voulez soutenir l'entreprise
française tout en achetant des écouteurs
de bonne qualité et bien je pense que là
vous avez de quoi faire tout commence là
d'or dans cette jolie boîte plutôt bien
mais il faut que ça c'est efficace en ce
qu'ils ont fait divers corps c'est
vraiment très premium vous l'ouvrez est
normalement vous avez ça à l'intérieur
je les enlever pour le tester vous vous
en douterez par contre ici ce qui est
vachement bien et on voit tout de suite
sont ces petits trous alors on peut dire
qu est ce que c est bien en fait c'est
une des spécificités de ce produit ce
sont des petits en bout à mémoire de
forme c'est qu'une fois que vous les ont
utilisés ils vont venir retrouver leur
forme initiale
un peu comme un aurélien est mort de
forme ça vient apporter un peu plus de
confort dans votre oreille et ça vient
en plus vous aider pour l'isolation
passive mais ça je vous en parle dans
quelques instants vous avez plusieurs
tailles pour toutes les oreilles vous
allez voir là va venir reprendre sa
forme initiale ensuite à l'intérieur
vous avez bien évidemment viens dans mon
petit lapin
de quoi venir leurs charges et ici en
usb c'est parce que oui si c'est l'usbc
ça se cache juste ici à l'arrière de
quoi bien changer vos petites ailettes
pour votre confort optimal et puis
surtout vous avez une doc qui est très
bien fait mais c'est bien le slogan ça
me fait rire magique avec android et ios
là pour que vous pouvez pas vous tromper
français c'est vraiment écrit noir sur
blanc et leur guide est vachement bien
conçu il vous explique effectivement
bien le contenu de la voie jusqu'aux la
grand classique mais surtout comment
obtenir un confort maximal vous avez
vraiment toutes les infos comment bien
les positionner ça j'ai voulu montrer
dans quelques instants comment appéré
les écouteurs la doc est très bien
construite ça permet vraiment à tout un
chacun aux mêmes personnes qui ne
connaîtraient pas du tout ce type au
logis de produits et savoir comment les
utiliser comment les charges et les
états enfin un truc est vachement bien
connaître l'état de la batterie les
capteurs intelligents ils vous prennent
vraiment par la main même pour les
sportifs connectés chaque écouteur
individuellement vous voyez sur près de
suisse ont vraiment bien bossé et ça on
le retrouve nulle pas entrer dans tous
les produits que je teste aujourd'hui
j'ai jamais eu cette boucle alors ghana
sur internet affectivement mais pour
toutes les personnes qui vont pas
forcément les sarouels vient vous allez
ça directement ici en français mais vous
l'avez également en anglais plus en plus
votre carte de garantie
donc ça c'est très bien ensuite tout ce
passe ici dans ce petit oeuf diva corps
qui est maintenu comme ça surtout qui
aimante et ça vous permet de crop venir
jouer leurs maîtres comme un petit
bilboquet si vous voulez vous amuser
vous pouvez le faire quand vous arrivez
ici vous voyez vos deux intra trueye en
laisse qui sont positionnées ici et qui
se recharge
vous avez ici de quoi leurs charges et
si c'est le capteur de proximité vous le
voyez là votre mousse à mémoire de forme
il ya un côté un peu zen quand je fais
ça ça me détend et puis je vais finir
par arrêté de trembler pavé tactile ici
et surtout la spécificité de ces
produits est bien c'est qu'il se
connecte indépendamment grâce au
bluetooth 5.0 ça c'est un tout qui est
assez intéressant
chaque intra va se connecter
individuellement à votre smartphone en
règle générale ce qu'on va retrouver
sait qu'on va avoir en intra en principe
celui de droite qui va se connecter au
smartphone qui sera l'intra mètres et
qui lui va transmettre au deuxième à
l'esclave là les deux se connecte
directement et ça va venir améliorer
l'expérience sonore alors regardez il ya
tout qui est très important à connaître
c'est l'installation de ces petites
bêtes là ce qu'il faut faire si vous le
prenez et vous le posez comme ça ça ne
tient pas il faut venir lévis et voulait
poser comme ça et vous tourner pour ça
rentre bien dans votre oreille et vous
faites exactement la même chose de
l'autre côté le positionner comme ça
dans l'oreille et ensuite un petit quart
de tour la tenue est très bonne je peux
pas voter
je peux me jeter à quelque chose près
bon je vais éviter quand même de me
faire mal de nabi mais le couple est
parent qu'a tenue est vraiment très
très bonne et surtout il ya un truc qui
est très cool c'est que j'ai une vraie
belle isolation passive d'une parce que
ce sont des intra et qui viennent le
boucher l'oreille et de deux parce que
vous avez cette mousse à mémoire de
forme qui va venir s'étendre pour ni a
complètement obstruée votre canal
auditif pour ne laisser entrer aucun
sont que ce soit du vent que ce soit
n'importe quoi vous êtes isolé vous êtes
protégé c'est plutôt bien alors ça c'est
le point positif
l'inconvénient de ce système là c'est
que ce que vous allez passer des appels
avec et bien vous vous entendez parler
vous n'êtes pas ouvert sur le monde
extérieur alors vous pouvez l'être
enlever un écouteur c'est ça vous
dérange mais en ce qui me concerne ça ne
m'a pas posé de problème
c'est après voilà tout un chacun de
savoir si vous avez ce système là ou pas
du tout parlons audio parlons musique
par une qualité sonore est ce que ses
antipodes de son à la hauteur ou pas du
tout et bien putté senti post 2 quand
vous les mettez quand vous écoutez de la
musique la première chose qui vous
frappe c'est que vous avez de la rondeur
on a des basses on les retrouve elles
sont présentes on n'a pas une chose de
très neutre on n'a pas quelque chose de
complètement linéaire c'est intra sont
flatteurs au niveau des basses est ce
que pour autant ça vient manger les
médiums et les aigus
la réponse est non pour ma part j'ai
adoré écoutez paul zone lips de vitalic
également do as tu de rammstein ou
encore still dre de dr dre voyez à du
hip hop et de l'électro il y à du métal
ça fonctionne très bien je me suis même
écouter maria callas je retrouve cette
précision au niveau des médiums aux
médiums et des aigus je vais pas avoir
une brillance parfaite mais par contre
la qualité est là a profité lease hl
équaliseur de mon application pour venir
modules et si je veux venir casser un
petit peu les laissons un peu trop grave
et bien je peux venir les kc je peux
venir accentuer un peu mais aiguë si je
vais récupérer un petit peu de brillance
mais globalement pour moi la qualité
sonore est vraiment au rendez vous edit
l'accord a bien bossé sur ces cintres on
a retrouvé ici les codecs sbc assez ici
pas d'appétit x de qualcomm pas de ldlc
l'utilisation extrêmement intuitive au
niveau tactile tactile sur la partie
droite est tactile également sur la
partie gauche
si votre téléphone sonne vous appuyer
pour décrocher quand vous avez terminé
votre plantation vous réveillez vous
raccrocher et si vous voulez refusé
l'appel vous faites un appui long et hop
ça jettera la personne son répondeur
pour écouter de la musique vous fait
lecture pause à droite ou également à
gauche vous appuyé deux fois à droite
morceau suivant deux fois à gauche
morceau précédent
c'est très intuitif voulait s'est
appuyée à droite vous allez augmenter le
volume voulait s'appuyer à gauche vous
allez baisser le volume
et vous appuyez trois fois à droite ou à
gauche vous aurez votre assistant vocal
qui sera disponible que ce soit google
assistant ou bien encore serré ici sur
un os et comme vous avez des capteurs de
présence dès que vous les mettez hop la
musique reprend et quand vous les
enlevez la musique s'arrête vous avez
jusqu'à 6 heures d'écouté avec vos
petits intra et vous monter jusqu'à 24
heures avec votre boîtier de recharge
autre point qui est plutôt bien ces
écouteurs vous pouvez les utiliser pour
aller faire du sport ils sont certifiés
ipx4 donc résistant à la sueur les
antilles paul's de diva corps ne sont
pas non plus parfait on pourrait venir
leur reprocher de ne pas avoir d'
applications avec un des collisions
notamment qu'on pourrait venir régler
directement ici y'a rien de très grave
puisque vous pouvez venir utiliser les
quoi l'isr de l'application partir de
laquelle vous allez écouter de la
musique
on pourrait également venir leur
reprocher elle la taille de cette boîte
où j'en avais déjà parlé lors de
représentations lorsque j'étais à vegas
c'est vrai que c'est quand même un peu
gros
dans une poche ça se verra mais rien
pour les faits un peu bilboquet eh bien
je pourrai vue pendant des heures donc
ça ne posera pas de ceux ci si vous
souhaitez les achetez vous êtes bien
évidemment mis un lien en bas dans la
description est à noter que si vous
habitez pas très loin de metz là où se
trouve le siège de diva corps et biens
d'yves accor a ouvert une boutique à
metz pour venir les récupérer
pendant la période de confinement en
click and collect des attractions
explosive au tarif de 149 euros
je trouve plutôt bien positionnée sur le
marché par rapport à leurs tarifs donc
si vous souhaitez acheter des intra soit
pour les fêtes pour noël pour les offrir
à quelqu'un
gentil paul de diva corps sont très très
très cool et surtout vous ferez
travailler le connard ce principe donc
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle à vous le
dire vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire comment est
ce que vous les trouvez les antilles
pose de diva qu est-ce qui vous plaisent
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté
la toute première version d'un type aux
antipodes un anti pause je coupe le mans
est est ce que ceci pourrait vous faire
de l'oeil
dites moi tout ça en bas en commentaire
sur ce je vous embrasse beaucoup d'amour
monde et à très vite
ciao
[Musique]